dans son atelier au mesnil-le-roi la
gérante de l'entreprise maza francs créé
depuis 2015 des jeux éducatifs en bois
depuis l'automne 2020 elle a lancé cette
tablette ludique pour l'apprentissage de
l'écriture
l'idée c'est de pouvoir accompagner
l'enfant dans le dessein de la lettre
sur les tablettes est indiqué le ductus
qui est le sens de l'écriture et qui
facilite une écriture plus fluide et
plus rapide
ça permet aussi aux enfants qui peuvent
être porteurs de handicap ou qui ont des
déficits moteurs justement de travailler
la gestuelle travail le poignet parce
qu'en fait ça travaille le poignet ça
travaille la précision
cette tablette a connu depuis quelques
mois un franc succès d'abord auprès des
parents puis des enseignants et du
personnel paramédical
j'ai travaillé au départ sur cette
tablette des minuscules cursive et petit
à petit les enseignants les parents
m'ont dit mais est-ce que vous pouvez
nous faire là aussi la tablette des
majestueux est ce que vous pouvez faire
les chiffres j'ai vraiment vu qu'il y
avait un vrai même besoin d'outils
d'outils pour accompagner les enfants
les élèves dans la mémorisation des
gestes de l'écriture apprendre à prendre
tout simplement à travailler la
motricité avec cet engouement annula
breton a décidé de s'agrandir
elle a trouvé un nouvel atelier plus
grand à maisons laffitte
il lui manque seulement de nouvelles
machines plus performantes elle a donc
lancé une campagne de financement
participatif sur hull
il me manque dix mille euros pour
compléter le financement
et ce qui me permettrait de passer
commande de machines cette campagne
ulule
effectivement c'est une collecte mais en
contrepartie vous achetez quelque part
vous précommandez la nouvelle édition
des tablettes d'écriture grâce à cet
argent la gérante va pouvoir développer
également de nouveaux supports de
motricité pour l'instant 4800 euros ont
déjà été récoltés la campagne de
financement s'arrêtera le 8 juillet